thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys and we have Mr Alex
Acosta today in the seat oh hello hey
hey man yeah I am yeah I watched a movie
I did watch it um I was a little
skeptical at first no spoilers because
nobody else watched it apparently so
basically what happened who watched it I
got to see it yet I watched it I don't
got three hours because I'm a busy man
it what it did if it towards at the end
I was kind of like
like you know moving my leg it felt like
three hours a little bit but it was just
like just because like I don't know I
think I was just drinking too much
caffeine or something like that so I was
just like it was long [__] sand
already it was long it wasn't sure it
felt it did not feel short but it didn't
feel like uh uh painfully long it was
still enjoyable was it Lord of the Rings
long no and I feel
anything out
if they cut something out they did cut
some stuff out did you see the other
scene yeah yeah but it was just like for
what I know about that I know yeah I
know about the scene too yeah but what
they've actually put out like I think
was good like I don't feel like they
could cut anything out from what's out
but it is almost three hours long enough
so what what's sick about it you like I
mean so far I've just heard length I
really enjoy the fact that it's very
like uh film Noir like very dark so even
like the opening scene it's like more of
like a psycho thriller yeah versus just
like a comic book live action which a
lot of the other Batmans are like
Christopher Nolan taking Batman you know
to where it was with the Dark Knight and
all the stuff that was like the most
serious version yeah but even when you
see that next to like this version of
the Batman with Robin pants and all that
stuff it's kind of like okay this is
like more of a dark cycle through so it
got darker darker and and the natural
version of like Batman as a character
he's very like detective yeah so this is
a very like detective Style Batman so
it's very similar to Batman Forever
that's cool yeah it's like
yeah he's more that's what I liked about
it though it's like he's more detective
like not some super rich guy that's like
all out and about and stuff like does Mr
Freeze get a lot of puns in this one
there's no Mr Freeze you miss a freeze
in the sequel that'd be so sad who's the
main villain uh Riddler Riddler why they
don't bring back I almost choked on my
skin
why don't they bring
that he's in there dude why not drink
penguin was done really well yeah but
for summer by Colin Farrell I always
thought that the penguin guy was like an
actual like mutant penguin which is what
the original Batman Returns shows us so
he's kind of like eating [__] fish
alive and wobbling but this one is just
but this one's like an AKA is it like a
mob gangster that's got like a scar in a
certain way and then he just calls
himself the penguin what's that that's
how he is in the long Halloween which is
like one of my favorite Batman books
ever it's a great Batman graphic novel
but he's just a he's just a mob boss
basically but I thought the penguin
story was because
um you know during that time and like
the industrial era of England babies
were coming out with yeah it was just
like the chemical change yeah a lot of
them were coming out looking like
penguin hands and [__] where their limbs
were stuck together I'm bored give me a
nickname
okay got the same accent from New Jersey
hey I'm born I want my smoke break
it's like this
they pop out we should form a union I
will say that uh it's Robert passes
Batman
is like probably my favorite Batman oh
[__] but but uh Christian Bale is my
favorite Bruce Wayne okay what about how
he kind of looks like Robert in the suit
it kind of looks like Robin stole the
Batman suit and he's like walking around
with it let me do that it's a little too
big Robin stole it it looks like Robin
in the suit like he looks like Robin if
that's it Robert Pattinson yeah I think
he just looks a little bit gaunt oh yeah
didn't he say he didn't want to lift for
this or something like that they said
that there was like a story that I
remember reading about how Robert
Pattinson didn't want to put on any
extra muscle to be the Batman and it was
like controversial because people were
like mad about it well he's not skinny
but he's not like just overly buffed for
no reason too there's again there's that
realism it's not like when you're
looking at Ben Affleck in the Batman
scene you're like
are you that huge because he has the
painted on apps yeah yeah well he looks
huge though he is a big guy he's [__]
hulking in that thing one of my favorite
parts of the movie I feel like this and
like the Joker is the score that they're
doing like the music that they're doing
yeah I mean even like them using
Nirvana's like something in the way was
like so perfect and then where they put
it at throughout the movie is just like
damn that shit's like so good it's nice
to grow up because we're getting older
and we watch them we watch Batman all
the way when I was [__] before Val
cream and windows uh what's his face Tim
Burton uh yes Michael Adam West Yes mine
was one like Arnold Schwarzenegger was
Mr Freeze and Jim Carrey was the Riddler
We Were Young then so as we're adults
now just still like find a way back in
the movie theaters to watch another
Batman reboot it's like I enjoy that it
gets more mature because I too as a
person of Matrix so I want to see more
[__] crazy stuff I want to see like
real blood I want you killing I want to
see death I want to see kind of real
world satire so that it feels like like
yeah we need a [__] Dark Knight
actual world that kind of stuff Thrills
me as I get older I'm the opposite
because I am in the real world I want to
see some more Tim Burton directions I
want to see Gotham City with [__]
crazy colors and [__] and crazy
characters you know like like that Dick
Tracy world oh my God
but I did like that about this too like
Gotham looked like a dirty like ghetto
like scary city to live in I felt like
yeah I felt like the whole move was good
I kind of went into it like I was saying
with speculation just because like
um I see that guy as the Twilight guy
and that's all especially like when that
was out my girlfriend at the time was
like I'm team whatever the hell vampire
or whatever Edward Edward Empire is what
she said yeah
just any vampire that's all I see him
yeah but then I saw him in that other
movie too the uh Lighthouse I was like
oh okay he's pretty he's fun in tenant I
feel like when I saw an antenna I was
like okay I'm no longer thinking you're
a vampire now yeah yeah the idea of you
walking up to a box office and be like
yo one for Lighthouse
what I I did so every
I go to the movies by myself because I
like to go to the movies by myself I saw
Batman by myself okay just because I
don't want to like have to worry about
anybody else but why if you're gonna go
by yourself why not yeah yeah because
Friday's so packed is when it's 5.50 I
know but Fridays I go like at 11 30 in
the morning
theaters are never packed I think there
was like five other people when I saw
Batman and when I saw Lighthouse I was
literally the only person in that movie
theater that one was a little hard too
because I was tired and it's black and
white way to watch Lighthouse yeah but
that one was good A lot of people in a
lighthouse yeah but it's immersive he
did really good I thought yeah he's not
like so I like that though he's not some
huge Jack like crazy [__] it's
just like some speaking of huge Jack and
crazy
um so if what's your voice
what's up oh my God so hard uh so what's
your superpower if you had a superpower
what would it be
I don't I feel like just from growing up
like I've always liked the Hulk but then
also it's just like then you can't like
have a normal life you know so I don't
know I I feel like in between Hulk right
in like Avengers end game where he's
like half Hulk half Bruce big and then
he's like the he's like hey take a photo
kids yeah but you can't even have a
[__] wardrobe dude all your [__] gets
torn up I don't only want to wear shorts
all the time uh you always have a g
string on yeah
I'll always like Wolverine Wolverine I
think that that [__] was dope because
like he can fight his healing too of a
long time he can heal he's always like
pissed off at everything that's me dude
imagine being Wolverine though and some
guy's like hey dude hit me that drinking
like no sweat and you're like shaking oh
my [__] god
I'm sorry he's a ghost right through his
hand he's like you can't heal her oh
[__]
which kind of is like what happened to
him right yeah all the time nightmares
and [__] A bunch yeah he killed people
yeah I don't really needs therapy that's
what he needs to balance him out a
little bit Yeah because he had too much
PT man X-Men was one of the best [__]
Saturday cartoons though right like I
remember [__] Gambit and Roe was like
they're like so in love but they
couldn't [__] touch and one time they
finally kissed and then she took his
powers and [__] and I'm like oh man if I
was Gambit I would just put like a full
body condom on and [__] the [__] out of
road
from just hold oh damn The Wolverine in
the cartoon was a different Wolverine
too his attitude and like he had a
different accent too he would like he'd
do that thing with blue one but it's
funny because you know like in in every
cartoon if the the guy with the sharp
weapon can never really cut anybody
because like like turtles the [__]
Leonard just hits the roof and kicks you
you just slash
Marine would always take out the two two
claws at the end and hold people's necks
yeah and they would go and he would go
sometimes the claw slips
but it never threatening people but it
never will yeah he had a count chocula
vibe to him
he was like Romanian or something yeah
something like that and cyclopsis
oh yeah what's your superpower
that's a good question what do you think
my superpower would be yours yeah just
just look at the earrings
superhero high level deflection
superhero in my head I was like that's
what I sonar but I wanted to hear what
you guys wait what's that Nightcrawler
could hear it no he's just a
Nightcrawler can teleport oh yeah yeah
dude what a useless power I could hear
from like what are you talking about
[__] was sick in the video game
ears dropper Wolverine has good hearing
ears today's video is brought to you by
fairy all right check this out dudes I
like to wear pretty much the same thing
all year round shorts t-shirts casual
stuff but the problem is I need
something that I can wear
all the time anytime whether it's kind
of in a nice place or kind of in a
beachy place I don't know it just I need
something that works for me
and that's why I like Verity because
their stuff is super high quality looks
good anywhere in a more casual setting
dress down setting and their stuff you
could wash you can put in your luggage
and it just feels good that's a brand
new clean looking look at the print dude
this stuff looks like it looks like a
dragon scales right now yeah it's pretty
cool
um I'm gonna do I have this pair right
here still got the tag intact because I
want to show you I really like a brand
when they put
um like details into even the packaging
and stuff like they use good rope here
they have all the info here you know
and I like these shorts with the
stretchy materials yeah and guess what
I'm already wearing their t-shirt right
here too it feels really good and smooth
yeah if you touch it it feels like one
of those things oh I could watch this a
billion times and it's gonna look new
every time so luckily Verity makes it
way easier because they make the perfect
clothes for all seasons and what's cool
is that they're a family-run brand
making high quality clothes at the
faradaybrand.com off director and use
code off the Record at checkout to snag
20 off all your new spring Staples look
at this man that's called off the Record
at Verity
f-a-h-e-r-t-ybrand.com off the Record
veritybrand.com off the Record
step will be like he's always like hey
guys
I was like where's the drop part
actually just dropping his ears so he
can listen to stuff yeah me too
[__]
yeah I'm the eavesdropper
with the [__] ears dropper you might
be like the thing
the thing oh yeah you don't feel
Fantastic Four because he's gonna sit
there and be a rock all day long yeah no
dude I'd rather I'd rather be the
eavesdropper
be quiet around I was like yo I got the
scoop you'll be like I believe this my
superpower
you know I I've always thought that
flying would be sick as [__] but then I
am at I want to be the guy who who flies
like but he can only fly eight miles an
hour
like a light cover yeah so it's like
it's sick how high can he goes you have
a maximum hike pass there should be six
feet
well before it gets too cold because if
you go up there it's [__] cold you're
like oh God damn it's cold they never
take that [__] they never do just be a
guy that can only fly in a downward
trajectory
like trust me I'm flying man well I
always thought that'd be great if you're
a suit if you're a superhero but all you
can only fly like 10 miles an hour and
then everyone's like waiting on you all
right they're like get like get a jet
you're like no I'll fly there I'll meet
you guys oh no you can fly right it's
like I better get to the jet
it's like what is Steve really do for
the team that should be our show right
instead of X-Men it's like it's like
because there's there's for sure X-Men
is like the star mutants the ones that
have the cool Powers too but for sure
there's a subset of like mutants that
got the whack is power just like b-class
and that should be us not not even B
Class I'm talking like CD class oh the
guy that can't fly that fast that's
great the guy that can only hear like 20
feet away and you're like oh that's it
fair that all the mutants in that world
were they got sick ass useful things
right there's got to be some mutants
that are just useless everybody has like
some crazy radical accident like did
anybody ever just have an accident
playing beer pong and then now like your
beer pong guy and they can turn into a
beer pong table
I'm beer pong guy like what do you do
he's like it turned into a beer pong
table and he's like so anybody want to
play beer
all right cool yeah we're tired being a
table than just a person
we should get those powers where it's
like almost like what the X-Men have but
then the weakest version of it
so it's like the d-man the F man like
like your Cyclops but your eyes are just
red you guys always have red eyes is it
just laser pointers like you just go
like this it's a laser pointer like it's
that it's that what you're looking
Cyclops you wouldn't like me if I'm
angry because my hands turn into ferns
oh [__]
that's a highly delicate
oh check this out snip snip snap
my Fern I have to maintain my Fern
my good Lord Wolverine is just like long
nails just fingernails just comes out
yeah what if you're just generally
annoying so you always say you wouldn't
like me when I'm me
you're just generally a shitty person
wouldn't like me
have you ever seen the movie called
Mystery Men I love mystery man that's
kind of that they're all the ones
yeah
we came up with it first nobody's just
about what's Joe's power
I just my power is Idle I don't get
tired after I come why
fall asleep that's a real power I would
say you can stop Asian hate but that's
also good yeah yeah yeah that's about it
I already embody that bro
it's all about Asian love now
I don't know I think that would be a
pretty good Tower is just after I
ejaculate I don't go to sleep it's
really good I just stay awake how would
you use that to fight bad guys though
well I guess the bad guys can't give you
handjobs anymore
the bad guy's like I think you are about
to go to sleep my friends
I know so then I'm just like that's what
you do buddy go ahead so do you think
hand jobber
sleeping oh no it's the hand jobber
don't worry we got Joe
bring out the fluffers and then there's
a guy there's a guy explained to his
girlfriend in the movie theater he's
like he's like so Hand driver is his
biggest hand
he's always trying to make him sleepy he
could never ever do it he's only trying
to make them it's like Unstoppable Force
they're gonna be doing this forever and
she's like whatever she's on her phone
Unstoppable person
is the man tied like kickboxer I'm on
[__] Force meets an immovable object
the hand jobber and JoJo sukawa guys
he's got with that power though with
that power
God I just come and I go I'm not gonna
sleep I'm wide awake hand driver
you're tired I am tired but you're not
gonna sleep
not for the come but I might just sleep
in general the hand dropper he used to
work at a dildo factory and there was an
accident a chemical art he fell in the
chemical coloring of the dildo yeah yeah
and now he gives hand jobs his hands are
fleshlights
he's wearing just yellow gloves he makes
you come quick dude so quick yeah so
when you when you see the [__] or in
a bank he's walking out with the money
you see a bunch of dudes who are like
the security guard they all got hit with
their pants
that's a great start because it shows
Joe and then you just see Joe go
[Laughter]
three hours later Steve coasts in I'm
here
sorry guys it's cold out there
Anthony Lee what's your power what's my
power dick just okay how about this I
think it's it's like one of those Powers
that's just human but you're good at
like dance yeah you could copy oh yeah
yeah
has changed instead of Mystique how she
could like like uh be completely a
different person you could imitate those
people with move with movements that's
it but I look like my
life but you can walk like Jojo so I'm
just like a like a Third Street
Promenade impersonation
really good though the best the best
like they don't hold a candle pretty
good so it's like we can see those
people in you so I'm like Rogue I gotta
take people superpower by my dance moves
so like if I'm like next to Joe I touch
them and now I don't sleep after it
that's good yeah
[Music]
I'm just like
he's not falling asleep it's pretty good
power he has a weak ass power but it
only lasts 30 seconds
I want to be able to watch Titanic every
time I close my eyes
at the beginning so it's only for you
well I know what it is I know what it is
he has a keyboard everywhere he goes and
when he plays music the whole crowd
feels what he feels so if he plays happy
music he can make a [__] whole War
stop dancing and [__] and the different
music he plays like uh affects his
facial hair oh that's nice like it gets
longer or shorter or like happy about it
or whenever I tell a story about someone
that died they actually live oh that's
good yeah I mean let's not go crazy here
let's keep it realized yeah I just dance
mimic people come on man bring it back
with resurrections one of the rules you
can't use in Aladdin
well once again so far Joe has the best
superpower oh yeah that's really good
and I even have a villain a nemesis the
[__] that's true God damn hand jobber
you at it again just robbing banks again
God damn it what happens checking
everybody off
oh but you know women are his Kryptonite
because he would be like you have no
penis what do I do
and they're like ethnicity yeah what is
his ethnicity I think he's Wario yeah
like very worrying because Wario looks
like Wario sounds like he's a little
molester yeah that's true he looks like
a little weirdo everyone knows it
everyone thinks it maybe some Waluigi so
that man's a good movie yeah would you
watch a all-female reboot of Batman the
way they did with Ghostbusters oh hell
yeah hell yeah dude all women all the
time my whole life let's take out all
the guys let's just do all women I've
got to say Zoe Kravitz is [__] hot
but it's not Julie Kravitz Amy Schumer's
playing every role
because it's like Nutty Professor but
you know okay Melissa McCarthy being at
two or no um you can only have one okay
only one what
only one only one only one of what
Highlander
[Music]